I just want to speak very briefly about
the school shooting in Nashville
Tennessee
you know
Ben and I have been doing this our whole
careers it seems
and uh
it's just uh it's sick you know we're
still Gathering the facts of what
happened and why
and we do know that as of now there are
a number of people who are not gonna did
not make it
including children
it's heartbreaking a family's worst
nightmare and I want to commend the
police who responded incredibly swiftly
within minutes and the danger
we're monitoring the situation really
closely Ben as you know
and we have to do more to stop gun
violence it's ripping our communities
apart ripping a soul this nation ripping
it's a very soul of the nation
and we we have to do more to protect our
schools so they aren't turned into
prisons
you know a shooter in this situation
reportedly had two assault weapons in
the pistol to ak-47.
so I call on Congress again to pass my
assault weapons ban it's about time that
we began to make some more progress but
there's more to learn but I just wanted
to send my uh
concern hearts out to so many parents
out there I've been to so many of these
sites as Ben knows but virtually
everyone
and uh one of the things you folks
should I know you do know but you should
focus on
you know just like when
in the military my son was in Iraq for
year other places you
so many
members of the military coming back with
post-traumatic stress after witnessing
the violence and participating in it
well these children
these teachers
you should be should be focusing on
their mental health as well
and so I'm grateful anyway
sorry to start off that way but I
couldn't begin without an acknowledging
what happened